after toiling through months of
restrictions
these spaniards are embracing what
nature throws at them
it's kind of weird we've never seen so
much snow in madrid it's like a kid's
dream playing in the snow
storm philomena brought blizzard
conditions to madrid
it turned roads into dance floors and
streets
into ski runs this in front of madrid's
prado museum
well it's wonderful something you could
never imagine
spain's meteorological agency said it
was the heaviest snowfall in madrid
since 1971.
meteorologists reported more than half a
meter of snow
in the capital i'm so happy
this is a spectacle of nature something
unusually beautiful in madrid
it's been incredible i felt i had to go
out and it's incredible
i have never seen so much snow snowmen
everywhere
the most magical places in madrid
covered in snow i'm having such a great
time really
i can't stop smiling
but the storm did cause mass travel
disruption
madrid's main international airport was
closed
as was much of its metro
the military was mobilized to clear
roads more than 600 were blocked with
snow
fifteen hundred motorists became trapped
in their cars
tow trucks were of little help in their
rescue
assimila
security forces have deployed in all
their capacity to prevent this
from affecting the prevention plans of
the coveted 19 pandemic or the
vaccination campaigns that communities
are continuing
the minister added that more of the fisa
vaccine is arriving on monday
they are evaluating the best way to make
sure it can still be distributed
on the front line health workers fought
the conditions to reach work on saturday
i did a late night shift today i slept
in a hospital bed
i do not know if i have to stay tonight
because there are people who cannot get
here
with covert 19 spain has weathered a
storm that few forecasts
in madrid philomena is child's play
charlotte ballas al jazeera